how to go and everybody its warned and
with spider-man far from home less than
one month away it's starting to get
really exciting and we're starting to
get a lot of new TV spots new trailers
and new leaks it seems like we're
getting a new TV spot at least a few
times a week and that will probably
continue until Spiderman far from home
comes out just like Avengers in game and
now there is a mid credit seen leak that
is going around that everybody has been
talking about and a lot of you have
asked me to talk about because it seems
very legit and based on what we've seen
in spider-man homecoming and what we
know about spider-man far from home it
seems like the route that they would
take the next spider-man film that we're
going to get right now we're just
calling it spider-man 3 a lot of you
have been asking me about it and I've
seen it on a few different sites they
pretty much all say the same thing just
worded a little bit differently so we're
gonna go ahead and talk about it and
break it down in this video but
obviously if you're trying to avoid any
possible spoilers for spider-man far
from home here is your spoiler alert and
of course take this leak with a grain of
salt it is an online leak it originated
in the Marvel Studios spoilers reddit
page and I've seen it on multiple
websites as well but just like Avengers
in game we got many leaks for the movie
and of course not all of them were true
only some of them and a reminder about
my giveaway when I hit 450,000
subscribers I will be picking three
winners and each winner will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection so be sure to
subscribe to my channel and like the
video to enter so this comes from
somebody who supposedly worked on the
mid-credits scene for spider-man far
from home and it reads the mid-credits
scene starts off in a dark room with
chilling and villainous music a defeated
and sad looking Mysterio looks out the
window from a skyscraper at nighttime
the shop is within the building looking
outwards so you can't see the building
itself a voice is heard in the
background which sounds Russian which
says something like he beat us once but
soon he's going to pay Mysterio turns
around and the voice is revealed to be
from the chameleon in his costume
Mysterio then says Dimitri thanks for
having my back out there
chameleon replies with don't worry there
are more of us right then the music gets
darker while the vulture similar outfit
as homecoming with a few modifications
scorpion outfit similar to comics but
few differences shocker
different outfit than homecoming
looks like the red and yellow suit from
the comics and a man in a business suit
walk in from another room the
businessman gathers the villains
together and says I have a proposal the
camera pans out to the outside of the
building which is the old stark slash
Avengers Tower which has the name Oscorp
in green font right where the stark logo
used to be now this is obviously a setup
for Norman Osborn and the sinister six
this is something that we actually
thought was going to be in spider-man
far from home by the way spider-man
homecoming went especially with its
characters after hearing reports that
scorpion vulture and chameleon are not
going to be in spider-man far from home
many people were wondering what happened
to the set up and spider-man homecoming
for those characters so we won't be
getting the sinister six in spider-man
far from home but according to this
league
the mid-credits scene is supposedly
going to set them up to appear in
spider-man 3 another point about this
mid-credits scene leak is that it
doesn't tell us anything about face 4
but this goes along with what Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige said when
he told us that we will not be getting
any information about face 4 until after
spider-man far from home so this
mid-credits scene sticks true to what
Kevin Feige said about face 4 it doesn't
really tell us anything about the future
of the MCU it really just tells us about
the next spider-man film now in the
first spider-man far from home trailer
that we got we saw the old Avengers
Tower in the background being rebuilt it
was under construction but in the new
clip for spider-man far from home that
we got the other day it was completed so
of course everybody is wondering what is
this new building and who is the person
that bought it well Norman Osborn buying
the old Avengers tower and turning it
into the Oscorp building makes perfect
sense and is pretty much what everybody
is speculating right now so there are
some big points to this mid-credits
scene leaked and it would be really
awesome to see the sinister six Norman
Osborn the Green Goblin and Oscorp in
spider-man 3 but let me know what you
think about this let me know if this is
something that you would like to see for
the mid credit scene for spider-man far
from home and like I said remember take
this with a grain of salt this could
very well just be fanfiction but we'll
find out when spider-man far from home
releases in less than a month so again
be sure to let me know your thoughts on
this and another reminder about my
giveaway when I hit 450,000 subscribers
I will be picking three winners and each
one will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection to
enter all you have to do is be
subscribed to my chain
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts in your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
to your desperation to save the universe
you killed half of its population yeah
you did it very Nass and all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby
now your